the tsunami brought chaos and
destruction to hundreds of miles of the
Sri Lankan coastline the moment it
struck was captured by a cameraman an
old bus station full of people traveling
on the public holiday resorts and
villages all along the southern and
eastern coasts were devastated 36,000
people died on the island but the
personal tragedy that befell teenagers
Robin Paul Fork and was never made
public over the years you know we
haven't told anyone our story you know
never came out in the media when it
initially happened hey I'm Rob and this
is my brother Paul in our early years
our parents took us on a round and
holiday to India which inspired them to
pull us out of school at 13 and 11 to go
on a trip of a lifetime discovering the
world now on the 10th anniversary the
brothers are telling their story how
they lost their parents in the tsunami
and why they started their flip-flop
business Gandhi's our story is very
unique in the sense of there's neither
brand that's been set up by orphans to
help fellow orphans when we initially
started we decided to put back 10
percent of the profits towards projects
when we came up with the the idea of
orphans for orphans in terms of the
message Rob and Paul were teenagers when
they went to Sri Lanka on holiday with
their parents and their two younger
siblings they had spent the previous
three years traveling around India being
taught by their parents we had this
crazy upbringing just seeing lots of
different things and different cultures
and learning just new things every day
they went to Sri Lanka for a Christmas
break surfing at the resort of whaling
Gama on the southern coast when the wave
hit on Boxing Day morning the two boys
were in their bedroom together just got
woke up by you know by some people
screaming we wondered what was going on
and water came into our room and then
before we knew it that was kind of you
know a brick wall kind of yeah
at 200 miles an hour whatever the speed
it was come coming at us and it was just
a case of fighting for our lives getting
to getting to the roof
they never saw their parents again the
parents sacrificed themselves to get our
youngest brother sister out of their
room and then they went their separate
ways and that's kind of yeah what
happened that Robert and Paul spent
hours searching for their family they
found their younger brother first and
finally at the end of the day they found
their little sister both had been pushed
up trees by their parents before they
themselves were washed away through the
chaos of the devastated country
the boys hitchhiked with a younger
siblings almost a hundred miles back to
Colombo quite lucky that we were brought
up like that soon we've said the other
day that if the tsunami happened to us
when we were just on a two-week holiday
we wouldn't have been as tough and we
wouldn't have doubted it how we have but
because we was traveling around and we
always saw people a lot worse off than
what we we were it kind of made it
easier to deal with
three years ago inspired by their
parents entrepreneurial spirit the
brothers set up their flip-flop business
which sprang from their love of
traveling we instantly knew this was the
perfect way of creating something
sustainable in which we could build a
brand based on our beliefs and this is
why we introduced orphans for orphans
the success of the brand boosts their
charity the Gandhi foundation which
raises money for children in India and
Sri Lanka that was like young shangkun
children we met that helps us get home
or you know helps us on the day you kind
of just grateful that those kind of
people showed just the the greatest side
of human nature honored on a day of
desperate need
see you then kind of feel yourself going
with they helped us in our hour of need
so you then want to want to help them
and this Christmas they're seeing the
concrete results as their first
orphanage rises from its foundations in
Sri Lanka this tsunami is basically
giving us no fear like so when we
started Gandy's out of our bedroom in
Brixton a couple of years ago we've come
up against some massive barriers and
brick walls and had legal cases and
stuff like thrown at us when we were
sleeping are safe for not being able to
afford our rent literally we've had it
all but because of being in the tsunami
it's kind of like gave us his attitude
that nothing worse can happen to us that
makes sense